do you have any idea the storm you've
created your order would you get in and
deliver the package like we were never
there we were compromised we had to
adapt you thought driving a tank over
half a Sarajevo was the answer yes sir I
did
do I look like a [ __ ] to you yes no sir
no I work here has not been fully
accomplished
rumor has it during World War two not to
stole gold from the French that was
worth a fortune
townspeople flooded the village stop
now it's all at the bottom of the lake
what do you say boys you realize what
we're talking about here recovering more
than three hundred million dollars in
gold bars and nobody's seen in 50 years
you're talking about a major
unauthorized operation under 150 feet of
water right in the middle of enemy
territory
is a chance to do something
extraordinary for the people of this
country hell yeah
it seems Serb headhunters are actively
searching to kill you you don't fight
nice yeah that's okay neither do I
you realize you broke every oath you
took always said I'll go out with a bang
I probably should want different
underwear huh there thanks Barmes i got
one behind us too
we reversed when boys
you